[Music]
we got the chance to read the Stephen
King novel from 1986 and then watched
the miniseries from 1990 and it's only
in 2017 that we finally got the chance
to see the first of two movies set in
this terrifying universe but if you are
a fan you probably notice that a lot of
things are different on paper on
television and on the big screen make
sure you watch the video and tell the
end to know what Pennywise is supposed
to really look like if you love horror
movies as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
how the cast of it should really look
bill as one of the most important
characters in this story we thought that
he would be really recognizable in the
book it was hard to imagine what
stuttering bill looked like but we had
some clues here and there in the story
we could read that Bills face turned as
red as his hair when he was coughing he
also had a goofball grin when he was
riding his bike then we could read about
his blue eyes and he was also described
as the tallest and most authoritative
figure in the group but many things
changed when Jaden liebherr her got the
role the actor looks nothing like the
boy described in the book but at least
they had the same heart and that's all
about matters
Ben this character might not be liked by
all the other kids but all the grown-ups
loved him because he was polite shy and
sensitive but when it comes to his book
most of the descriptions revolved around
his weight this is one of the reasons
why he was bullied then used to wear an
Ivy League t-shirt but when kids started
making fun of him he decided to stick to
loose clothes instead his look also
changed when Henry decided to carve his
name into his stomach a terrifying scene
that we all remember from the movie this
time the actor Jeremy Rae Taylor looks
exactly like the VIN that we imagined
and we'd bet that this is exactly what
casting directors thought when they
first saw him Ritchie if you read this
book you know that Ritchie is a trash
mouse who can't keep quiet and that's
what we loved about him however some of
his jokes were really inappropriate so
we think that it was a good decision to
forget about some of them
instead he became an annoying little boy
when it comes to his look Ritchie's
appearance was always described as
slightly awkward which didn't help with
the fact that his mouth constantly got
him in trouble and we also constantly
heard about his teeth and his glasses
being broken kicked or dropped the
screenwriter might have chosen a
different way to represent this
character but when it comes to his look
Finn Wofford was the best actor the
casting directors could find Mike as he
was from the only black family in the
little city Mike easily stood out and
this is what made him a victim of
bullies however if you read the book
you'll notice that his family really
changed in the movie his parents were
alive in the book and he used to work
for them which is what gave him the
chance to help the losers Club but in
the new movie his parents both passed
away in a fire and mike was raised by
his grandfather instead when it comes to
his look he is always described as
incredibly fast agile and slim this is
why the farm kid easily escaped the
bullies the story might not be the same
but we can totally imagine chosen Jacobs
in the role of Mike Eddie
we couldn't find a lot of descriptions
of this character in the book so it was
hard to cast the wrong person but no
matter what we had some clues his mother
was always convinced that he was going
to hurt himself because he was small and
fragile even when he was an adult his
face was described as thin and delicate
looking it didn't help that most of the
descriptions of the character centered
around asthma but if there is one little
thing that we learned it is that he had
grey eyes it was hard to cast the wrong
person for this role but what we love
the most about Jack Dillon grazier
is that he really brought life to this
character Beverly as the only girl of
the losers Club it was easy for this
character to stand out in the book she
wore cheap and old clothes that didn't
even fit her but Ben still thought that
she was the prettiest girl he had ever
seen Beverly has long urban hair gray
green eyes and milky skin however in the
novel she was always nice to the members
of the losers Club so they weren't
really impressed by her but in the movie
the young boys just go gaga over the
presence of a girl no matter what we can
say that Beverly
kept her beautiful look and Sophia
Lillis was the perfect actress to
portray that it's only the reaction of
the boys that changed Henry and let's
not forget about the characters that we
love to hate like Henry the bully as the
oldest member of the group he was 12 but
big for his age however time traveling
from the 50s to the 80s changed him a
little bit he used to have a flattop
haircut used a lot of Wax
and more a pink motorcycle jacket with
an eagle in the back however as the
movie was set three decades after he
lost his jacket and his look was more
adapted to the 80s no matter what we
could still feel the 50s vibe in this
character anyway we won't talk too much
about Nicolas Hamilton's look because we
don't know what he is going to do if we
upset him Patrick he might not be the
leader but he was probably the most
terrifying bully the book wasn't really
specific when it comes to his
description but we still know that
teachers thought he was a big lump of
clay that had been crudely fashioned to
look like a boy with his slack and
pallid moon face and his low IQ score
grownups underestimated him but only the
kids knew how crazy he was Stephen King
fans were surprised to see Owen Teague
in the role of Patrick and even thought
that he would be a better Victor but
when we saw him acting we immediately
changed our mind Stan this young boy was
bullied because he was a grade B he was
also religious but even if he was a Jew
Eddie said that stereotypes didn't hold
up for him because he had a regular nose
and he was always broke we are not sure
that is a compliment when it comes to
his look Stan was described as
fastidious and people could easily guess
it when they looked at him he also had
black hair which is one of the only
features mentioned in the book when you
look at the actor widel f you can see
his hairs brown however he does have a
similar personality which we can easily
see on screen Pennywise once you see him
you remember him forever because you'll
meet him many times in your nightmares
in the book his face was painted white
he was bald except for the tuft of
orange hair on each
side of his head and Georgie also
realized that his eyes were not yellow
but blue that's a lot different than
what we saw in the movie as he had a
little bit of hair on top of his head
and his eyes looked darker no matter
what Pennywise always looks terrifying
if you could be one character from
Stephen King's it who would it be don't
be shy to answer in the comment section
down below we'd love to hear what you
think and that's it for how the cast of
it should really look for more stories
like this make sure you watch small
details in it that only true fans
noticed thanks for watching
[Music]